Reuben is with us in Los Angeles hi
Reuben welcome to the Dave Ramsey show
hey are you doing Dave better than I
deserve sir what's up in your world well
I have a lot to ask you but I got to put
it short and simple um I'm a father of
five I've been working since about of
the high school ever since I know it's
going to be a dad so since I was 17 so
now I'm 30 I feel like I have nothing to
show for nothing save nothing put away
and now where I'm working it I think is
one of the best jobs I've ever had not
making about close to 50,000 and are you
I wanted a repurchase a house we lost a
house couple years ago and it's showing
that I owe 30 up close to $40,000 and
other stuff and depth so the previous
loan from the house and while my
question is where do I start what can I
do I just feel like I live paycheck to
paycheck it just feel like I don't make
enough or I'm just not being more
responsible with the money well I think
we can all make more and we can all be
more responsible that's everyone
including me and so you're probably no
exception to that either
you're doing a good job you're providing
for your family $50,000 with five kids
in Los Angeles is not a lot of money you
know you're not rich but you aren't and
so I'm not going to yell at you about
being wasteful or something like that
you're not wasteful you're doing
probably a pretty dadgum good job you
probably had some times along the way
where you stubbed your toe and made some
bad decisions and that's where some of
that bad debt and stuff comes from and
so if I'm in your shoes what am I going
to do
well I'm going to work on both sides of
the equation the income side and the
outgo side let's start with the income
side on the income side the short term
way to get money in extra is obviously
extra jobs it may be a smart smart small
business on the side that you do it may
be just delivering pizzas but you get
the income up temporarily long term you
get the income up by really sitting down
and saying hey where do I want to be in
five years and what are the steps I've
got to take
be there if I don't want to make fifty
in five years I want to make a hundred
in five years what have I got to do
where do I want to be what's my dream
and if you're 15 or you're 25 or you're
55 you always ask yourself what do I
want to be when I grow up and you keep
working towards that step by step by
step do you I need to take some classes
do I need to get an apprentice program
and you begin systematically on the
income side long term to get that up now
on the outgo side what you do is you sit
down with your spouse and you look at
how much money you got going out the
door and you do a written gameplan where
every dollar has a mission every dollar
has a name every dollar as a direction
that you're telling it to go on paper on
purpose before the month begins and as
you do that you're going to feel like
you've gotten a raise because you do
have some wasted money if you don't have
a written budget if you don't make every
dollar behave it won't behave money will
leave you when you don't crack the whip
on it and the budget is the whip in the
chair and you're the lion tamer and
you're making those dollars dance you're
making them behave on paper every single
month on paper on purpose every dollar
is named every dollar is given a mission
your spouse is in agreement every month
for the rest of your life you do that
that's a real step towards becoming
wealthy and it'll make the money work
much harder and so we get the income up
temporarily and long term on the one
side of the equation on the other side
of the equation we look around we go cow
we got a big car payment we got here
with this car we've you know we could
have a garage sale we could pay off this
debt now once you get yourself in
control and you get current with your
existing bills then you make a list of
the old bad debt and you begin to work
your way through it then you go call the
smallest one and you settle it and you
get it in writing and you get that one
knocked off your credit and you don't
have that bad debt outstanding anymore
and then you go to the next one and then
you go to the next one and then you go
to the next one you work your way
through a debt snowball on your bad
debts and while you're staying current
on your other stuff I would do that
actually after you not only stay current
but after you knocked out any current
debts that you have but it's going to be
it's going to be a journey for you it's
going to take you a little while Rubin
but but you can do it
as you get your income up and you get
control of the income that you have and
you get some of your expenses down
you're going to move yourself right in
the right direction to begin to clean
this up and get control and get a sense
of winning hold on if you'd like I'm
going to put you on hold I'm going Kali
pick up I'm going to give you a copy of
our New York Times best-selling book
biggest book we've ever done millions
and millions and millions of copies
called the Total Money Makeover and it
will lead you exactly through what I'm
teaching you to do right here on the
radio hey thanks for the call hold on
this is the Dave Ramsey show
you